you
you
you
you
the briefing will now begin at 2:30
yeah
yeah
city boy - yes
hey Christian just check
Oh
[Music]
so I'm sorry we are very late you guys
I'm sorry to keep you waiting
I was working with the President on
something and he wanted me to hand this
out to you all and I have it here so I
want to read it to the American public
directly from the president it has been
suggested that we should rename as many
as ten of our legendary military bases
such as Fort Bragg in North Carolina
Fort Hood in Texas Fort Benning and
Georgia and a list goes on these
monumental and very powerful bases have
become part of a great American heritage
in a history of winning victory and
freedom the United States of America
trained and deployed our heroes here and
won two world wars
therefore my administration will not
even consider the renaming of these
magnificent and fabled military
installations our history as the
greatest nation in the world will not be
tampered with respect our military so
that was directly from the president we
spent some time working on that and I
wanted to deliver that to you all so I
wanted to take us through few other
things relating to the corona virus
first the corona virus task force
briefing was held yesterday I was in it
and there's some very good news that I'd
like to share with you I don't know if
you all saw there were two studies that
came out very strong studies in the
journal Nature and in Europe which had a
very similar epidemic profile to the
United States 3.1 million lives were
saved due to mitigation and the efforts
taken by the European governments and as
dr. Burks noted to me she sent this to
me just before I walked out here she
said it suggests that the United States
also prevented over three million deaths
thanks to the efforts of President Trump
and the American people another study
found that the shut down efforts
prevented 50 million additional
coronavirus cases so those are two very
encouraging studies underscoring the
work of the American people also the
Washington Post noted that these two
reports use completely different methods
to reach similar conclusions they
suggest that the aggressive and
unprecedented shutdowns were effective
at halting the exponential spread of the
novel coronavirus
so thank you washington post's for that
good reporting the department of
agriculture secretary sonny perdue also
had some very good news and the task
force briefing i was at yesterday
america's meatpacking facilities at one
time it looks like they were going to
need to close that was unacceptable to
the administration so we took action the
coronavirus task force took action and
now i'm pleased to report that these
meatpacking facilities are operating at
ninety five percent capacity compared to
twenty nineteen we have beef operating
at ninety eight percent capacity pork
and 95 percent in poultry at ninety
eight percent throughout America's
extraordinary efforts to slow the spread
president Trump ensured that the meat
supply chain stayed functional and
robust by directing these meatpacking
facilities to safely operate in
accordance with the CDC and OSHA
guidelines his efforts secured America's
continual access to a steadies food
supply chain and then finally and very
importantly I have some great data
points to share on coronavirus testing
capacity and minority communities animal
brett dois shared this with me yesterday
and last night as well he said that when
we look at testing sites president
Trump's public-private partnership and
with retail companies has proven quite
successful testing sites are operating
in 49 states with 70% of these sites
located in communities with moderate to
high social vulnerability z' and social
vulnerability takes into account race
ethnicity housing and economics language
barriers and other factors also
federally qualified health centers their
FQHCs serve 29 million patients patients
in 12,000 communities across the nation
they provide care to one in five of
those uninsured one in five in rural
Americans one in five of one in three of
individuals below the poverty line and
more than 1.3 million homeless men and
women in nearly a million migrant
agricultural workers and 92 percent of
these FQHCs now offer Cova tests and
we've awarded them 583 million dollars
to a thousand three hundred eighty five
of these facilities and finally finally
I promise my last announcement the HHS
office of minority health issued a
competitive funding opportunity to build
a strategic network
of national state territory tribal local
and community-based organizations that
deliver vital health information and
support linkages to services for racial
and ethnic minorities and this this
announcement this network is scheduled
to be awarded at the end of June and is
expected to reach at least 40 million
individuals from racial and ethnic
minorities these updates I was told by
bread flour were received very well at
the Senate hearings and we thank the
vice president Mike Pence for doing an
amazing job leading our Crona virus task
force into President Trump who has led
in bringing America through the corona
virus pandemic and with that I'll take
questions Kristin thank you so much this
is the president regret tweeting out a
baseless conspiracy theory about a 75
year old protester on the morning the
president was asking questions about an
interaction in a video clip he saw and
the president has the right to ask those
questions regret tweeting out this
protester was assaulted the president
does not regret standing up for law
enforcement men and women across this
country and let me say this and just
give you a little bit about the mindset
behind the president's tweet but we're
living in a moment that is it seems to
be a reflexively anti police officer and
it's unacceptable to the President and
this tweet that he sent out he was in no
way condoning violence he was not
passing judgment on these two officers
in particular but what he was saying is
this when we see a brief snippet of a
video it's incumbent upon reporters and
those who are surveying the situation to
ask questions rather Thomas president to
have facts before he tweets anything
wrong
the President did have facts before he
tweeted out that undergirded his
question is conspiracy theory
faceless conspiracy no not at all I
won't acknowledge that because look you
had let's contrast this to the George
Floyd situation which that horrific
video that we all saw every single
police officer that I saw across the
country came out and said this is an
inexcusable action and I condemn this
police officer in this case there were
57 police officers who said I resign in
protest over the way these two officers
were handled and the president says
those law enforcement officers have a
right to be heard John said anything
justifies that 75 year old man being
pushed down to the ground like we also
the president does not condone violence
he wants to see the appropriate amount
of police force used in any given
situation including this one but he
believes that the officers have a right
to be heard his brother is here
testifying as the White House invited
him here to meet with the president the
president has repeatedly acknowledged
George Floyd his passing the egregious
Nevada trosset II and has called the
family by phone as he did last week yes
the president has got an event tomorrow
in Dallas and a church in which he'll
meet with faith leaders he'll also meet
with law enforcement officials small
business owners the theme is a plan for
holistic revitalization and recovery
will the president be announcing any
policy in regards to police reform
tomorrow and what might that policy form
yeah so that's a very important question
and as it stands currently the president
has spent the last ten days quietly and
diligently working on proposals to
address the issues that the protesters
have raised across the country
legitimate issues and that body of work
I'm told is reaching its final edits and
we hope to produce it for you in the
coming days I can't promise you it's
tomorrow but in the coming days we look
to deliver that they will tomorrow be
about what will be a listening session
as he had on Monday with law enforcement
or might there actually be some concrete
policy proposal yeah we'll be around the
executive level it will be a round table
much like what you saw with law
enforcement officers earlier in the week
stay on that theme for a second in terms
of reform ideas that the president could
support Democrats have floated some in
the House Senate Republicans led by Tim
Scott were working on others things like
banning chokeholds banning no-knock
warrants independent process to
investigate misconduct could the
president support issues like that so
again don't want to get ahead of the
announcements what I would say is each
issues being looked at as to what would
make a difference every thing that
you've suggested has certain
ramifications so he has to look at each
of these in great detail as he's done
over the last few days and I would just
note one thing that AG Barr said was
that in the democrat bill they talked
about needing to reduce immunity to go
after bad cops but that would result in
police pulling back so that is one thing
that is a non-starter qualified immunity
is that a red line for the president
that's a non-starter in the democrat
legislation yes John institutional
racism in this country and institutional
racism in law enforcement okay answer
this question I think this is the fourth
time I've been asked it and I've said
each and every time there are in
justices that we have seen clearly that
tape of George Floyd was inexcusable
gut-wrenching difficult to watch it was
really a beautiful funeral yesterday all
the great testimonies to his life we
recognize those and justices Sandra
bland another example but this president
knows fundamentally that most police
officers in this country are good that
the 750 men and women that have been
injured that David Dorn the police
officer who was killed and Patrick
underwood the law enforcement officer
who was killed are emblematic of what
police in this country stand for that is
the best that is the brightest and that
is our domestic heroes
is what I'm asking it now is does he
believe that action needs to be taken to
fundamentally change the way law
enforcement is done in this country to
make fundamental changes so that there
isn't the kind of disparities that we
see for long well the president's
looking at various proposals and I would
say this president has done a whole lot
more than Democrats have ever done when
it comes to rectifying and justices
where you had the crime bill of the 90s
which created great racial disparities
in our justice system and president
Trump rectified some of those with the
first step back so president Trump's
about action and he's shown that and he
recognizes and justices and acts
promptly when he sees them so I haven't
spoken to him on that specific one he
does as I noted at the top of this
briefing fervently stand against the
renaming of our forts these great
American fortresses where literally some
of these men and women who lost their
lives as they went out to Europe in
Afghanistan and Iraq and all across this
world to win world wars on behalf of
freedom a lot of times the very last
place they saw was one of these forts
and to suggest that these forts were
somehow inherently racist and their
names need to be changed is a complete
disrespect to the men and women who the
last bit of American land they saw
before they went overseas and lost their
lives for these forts
one case said that Justice Department is
engaged in kind of a regular conduct to
benefit a political ally of the
president many urge the presiding judge
in the case to deny an attempt by the
government to dismiss the charges what
is the White House reaction I've got the
first I'm hearing about I'd point you to
DOJ on that criticize the president's
decision to reduce the number of US
troops in Germany some saying that they
will embolden Russia if we if the United
States does that did the president make
that decision to punish Chancellor
Merkel for deciding not to come to the
g7 in June look I have no announcements
on that front and he never makes
decisions to punish certain world world
leaders he acts in the best interest of
the United States one of the things that
the president said in his tweet was that
the gentleman fell harder than he was
pushed how is how does that work in
terms of physics okay the president
raised several questions based on a
report he saw he has a right to ask
those questions and where he stands is
squarely with law enforcement he was
making no judgments not condoning
violence not saying what happened in
this case with these two officers was
right or wrong but he's standing back
and saying we need to ask questions
before we destroy lives and convict
people in the court of public opinion
yes the Federal Reserve and Steve we
news from said today the US will
definitely need another round of
stimulus how urgent is that for the
president I mean how soon do we expect
him to meet with Democrats to discuss
the next legislation yeah it's a good
question he met on a potential face for
policy last week it was a very promising
discussion with his economic advisors so
that's in the works as to when and if we
see that but it is a topic of discussion
he was encouraged by the jobs report we
were supposed to leave lose 7.5 million
jobs we ended up gaining 2.5 million a
swing by 10 million it was described to
me as one of the by one famed economists
as one of the worst miscalculations of
economists and history to be off by 10
million that's the size of Michigan so
the president's encouraged because what
we're seeing is a belief in the Trump
economy and the Trump presidency what
we're seeing is the markets or we're
seeing that SP have its best 50-day
track record in history because they
believe in a president that has
free-market policies that got us to the
hottest economy modern history and will
get us there again elevated for years
and also this week we heard from the
National Bureau of economics research
saying that the u.s. officially entered
a recession what is the White House
response to that we believe that next
month's job jobs report will be robust
the president has been clear that q4 he
expects it q3 to be a transition period
q4 to be robust and next year to be a
very hot year and I would note that
those in the prediction business they
were off by 10 million that's not too
good so I'd go back and look at some of
the models that were often on how
extraordinary the jobs report was last
time including 300,000 new jobs for
black Americans yes thank you so much
the president met with Mitch McConnell
today we understand
kind of fill us in on what that
discussion was about so I have no
announcements on that front
those were his private meetings so no
announcements out of that Jonathan's
question you know a lot of people are
concerned that there is you mentioned
justice disparities there's a lot of
concern of some Americans that police
officers treat black individuals and
people of color differently than white
individuals does the president share
those specific concerns here's what he's
concerned about he's concerned about
what the and I've told you he's
addressed in justices with Sandra bland
and George Floyd and has repeatedly
acknowledged that but here is an in
addition to that his concern put very
well by New York's Police Benevolent
Association president Michael Mehra our
legislators are failing us our press is
vilifying us he's saying us as police
officers stop treating us like animals
and thugs we've been vilified and it's
disgusting when you have a sitting
congressman Ilhan Omar calling cops
cancer what do you think that leads to
the AP reported on a shooting in front
of a police department today in
California
let's stop vilifying our officers let's
recognize injustice where we see it but
recognize all of us in here are safe
because of our police officers doing
their job each and every day people of
color are not treated the same by police
and that is what many of the protests
have been about does the president share
those specific concerns the President
believes most of our police officers are
good hard-working men and women like
David Dorn who was killed among these
riots like Patrick Underwood who was
killed among these riots those are our
police officers they are best they are
our brightest they're absolute places
the places of injustice we're addressing
those we're looking at legislative
proposals and Yeo's and you know what
ultimately is determined we'll see in
the coming days as to what will work as
a policy prescription but stop vilifying
our officers because they deserve better
than that they're out there they're
working hard 750 injured just in the
last week and a half and we need to
recognize that yes
is the president disappointed that more
Republicans have not lined up to support
the questions he asked to choose your
characterization of it many people also
characterize it as a conspiracy theory
and secondly has the president reached
out either to the injured gentleman or
to the police officers involved um so
first of all President Trump I would say
he's not focused on what Republicans are
saying or not saying on the hill he's
focused on making changes as I said he's
been diligently hard at work the last 10
days and that is where his focus
squarely lies at the moment yes thank
you and as he reached out to other the
gentlemen I'm not that I'm aware of no
not that I'm aware hello you started
this briefing reading off some
statistics about successive mitigation
efforts on the spread of kovat but we're
now seeing a spike in cases in more than
a dozen states and increased
hospitalizations and a lot of those as
well
so on many public health experts
attribute these spikes to Memorial Day
weekend gatherings and other aspects of
the reopening process before these mass
protests so why is President Trump
continuing to urge reopening giving
given this trend and should we be
slowing down a little bit on the
reopening process as we see cases like
first let me know as it pertains to
Memorial Day a week ago today the vice
president's team told me I was an intact
force that day but that it was said that
in fact that there was no linkage to
Memorial Day as being some point of
spurring wild outbreaks and rises across
the nation what I would say though I
talked to dr. Burks and she said what
we've seen is that in general April
averaged out to be about 30,000 cases a
day May was about 25,000 cases a day
currently we're at around 20,000 cases a
day and you've got to look in a nuanced
way at each of these states like her
instance Texas is one of the places
where they're saying we're seeing a
steady slope not a huge rise but part of
its in and due to the fact that they're
testing and long-term care facilities
and in prisons and the more testing you
do the more cases you identify
Trump is planning to research campaign
rallies within the next few weeks
what sort of precautions is he going to
be taking in his rallies for the safety
of the rally goers we have no rallies
announced just yet you're right about
the two-week timeline that was put
forward but we will ensure that everyone
who goes is safe but no specific
announcements on that front and I would
direct you to the campaign for more
information on that yes yes thanks
taking my question Owen Jenson with EWTN
news we've seen thousands of people in
the streets protesting exercising their
constitutional right those are tours
doing it peacefully at the same time
churches in many cases told to limit
their gatherings in some cases to ten
are no more does the president see a
double standard there constitutionally
speaking and if you know can you explain
please their absolute double standards
that we've seen and that's why the
Justice Department set up a task force
if you will or a group to look at civil
liberties as during coronavirus
shutdowns you know I read about one case
where you had allowance of outside
gathering and protest but indoor
churches could not gather even with
socially distance protocols
he absolutely sees an issue there have
been several cases pointed to where
people attending church in their cars
were targeted by law enforcement
officers so that that's unacceptable you
know people should be allowed to worship
we have a First Amendment in this
country there's a way to safely do it I
went to Mass and was able to safely
attend distance from people and there
were appropriate protocols that were
taken in that case and that's what we
hope to see as the president made
eminently clear a few weeks ago for all
churches to reopen is he happy with the
progress or no he's happy with the
progress I've seen in a in fact that
very week a church that I visited
reopened a church down the road for me
so I think he gave a lot of courage to
the faith community to reopen to do so
safely and look here we are I think four
weeks later and we haven't been hearing
about you know rampant outbreaks and
places of worship the First Amendment's
a beautiful thing people have a right to
go to church or mosque or synagogue yeah
30 bucks
still coded the Presidency's put your
concert so far about November the Kobe
situation whether people are going to be
afraid to go to polls or whether it's
going to be a lot of delays because of
the comment he recently said it's a long
way off I think we need to put the
pandemic would have died out by then
essentially but given that it hasn't
actually gone away if people are still
dying every day and there are some
spikes and it's not that far away
five months are any measures being taken
at all to to guarantee that this
election is going to go smoothly and
everybody wants the vodka boat yeah well
I you know I've not seen much criticism
of the protests and socially distance
and mitigation efforts I think there's a
way to safely vote if you can safely
protest and that's what the president
would like to see there's a way to
safely vote there's a way to safely go
to church and you're asking a
hypothetical about something five months
from now at a time ironically on when
the media hasn't expressed much outrage
about a lack of mitigation efforts taken
by some of the protesters is the
president concerned the protest could
lead to another outbreak of coronavirus
and a second question president should
say that he does not believe that death
toll and coronavirus case figures show
some country the citrus they figure from
Brazil is the White House concerned that
the Brazilian government is writing
information about paveed 19 so I haven't
spoken to him about the Brazil numbers
but I have heard him on several cases
probably at least five mention that he'd
seen what's going on in Brazil and he
was hurt to see how many people have
been affected by Cova down there so he
has mentioned Brazil specifically I
believe he even sent some ventilators to
Brazil because we had such an overflow
of ventilators here because America
really under the leadership of President
Trump snapped into action and shored up
what was supposed to be a ventilator
shortage and delivered this
administration delivered so I would just
note that that he's mentioned great
concern for the people of Brazil
the president will serve the protests
could lead to another outbreak for the
house now we're monitoring that you know
right now we're encouraged to see that
cases have declined month over month but
you know the Vice President as I walked
out here said the task force is well
aware of monitoring individual
situations in particular States
thank you thank you going back to where
you started with the statement about
renaming the military bases if Congress
were to send over verse say the Defense
Authorization with language that were to
remain one of these bases for someone
who say was a general who won the Civil
War would the president veto the Defense
Authorization the president will not be
signing legislation that renames
America's forts it's important to note
you know Fort Bragg for example it's one
of the largest military installations
it's home to tens of thousands of brave
American soldiers and when you think of
Fort Bragg we think of the brave
soldiers that deployed from there we
think of all five World War two Airborne
Division's 82nd the 101st the 11th the
13th and the 17th all trained at Fort
Bragg the 555th Parachute Infantry
Battalion this was the first black
parachute battalion trained at this fort
we must recognize the sacrifices made by
these men and women some of whom saw
Fort Bragg for the last time before they
went overseas and we've got to think of
the Fort Bragg soldiers that have led
humanitarian option operations like in
Hurricane Katrina and the earthquake in
Haiti we've got to honor what has
happened there not rename it so that is
an absolute non-starter for the
president I mean I would also note my
question of that General David Petraeus
is one of those people who went through
Fort Bragg a number of times
those first command was at the Fort
Campbell Kentucky he penned a quite
lengthy and detailed editorial about the
reasons why those bases should be
renamed saying it's ironic that American
soldiers and Marines are being trained
at bases named for people who fought
against the Union back in the Civil War
that many of the people for whom these
bases are named were leaders held in
questionable regard but who were
elevated during the Lost Cause movement
he goes on to say we do not live in a
country to which Braxton Bragg henry l
bangor robert e lee can serve as an
inspiration what does the White House
say to that particular point Bragg is
known for the heroes
within it that train there that deployed
from there and it's an insult to say to
the men and women who left there the
last thing they saw on American soil
before going overseas and in some cases
losing their lives to tell them that
what they left was inherently a racist
institution because of a name that's
unacceptable to the President and
rightfully so and I would also note
where do you draw the line here I'm told
that no longer can you find on HBO gone
with the wind because somehow that is
now offensive where do you draw the line
is it should George Washington and
Thomas Jefferson and James Madison be
erased from history what about FDR and
because of internment camps you know he
should he be erased from history or
Lyndon Johnson who has a history of
documented racist statements and finally
what about people that are alleged by
the media to be segregationist NBC tells
us Jill Biden didn't just compromise
with segregationists he fought for their
causes in schools experts say CNN tells
us letters from Joe Biden reveal how he
sought supportive segregationists in the
fight against busing in Washington Post
tells us that Biden's tough talk on 1970
schools desegregation plans could get
him new scrutiny and there are several
more that where that came from so I'll
leave you with the question should we
then rename the Biden Welcome Center
thanks very much guys
you
one two
one two